- All right y'all, I
search high and low for
the most heartwarming stories
and present them here.
This is what I'm liking.
- Elise is an athletic trainer
at a high school near Boston.
After eight years of dating her boyfriend,
she was antsy for him to pop the question,
cuz I said eight years y'all.
Apparently so were her students.
Check out their adorable reaction,
when Elise finally got the ring.
(student yells)
- She got the ring.
- Oh my God. I'm actually about to cry.
(student yells)
- Oh my god! Elise I'm
'bout to cry right now.
Oh my god!
(student yells)
- I'm actually crying!
(audience cheers and applause)
- So amazing.
We have Elise on the line right now.
Congratulations!
(audience cheers)
- Thank you.
- So it seems like the kids
were really invested in your love life.
They were very excited ma'am.
- Yeah. I mean, so I've
been there for five years.
I've been working as an
athletic trainer there
and you know I've shared with them.
And so when they found
out it's been eight years,
and that I was thinking maybe it was time,
the proposal was coming, they
just like hopped right on it.
They wanted to give him
deadlines, everything.
But we did let him do his own
thing, which was really sweet.
It was awesome.
Now they're just demanding invites
and they wanna help plan the wedding, so.
- Aw, well you clearly
have a special relationship
with your students.
That's, it's so important.
My mom is a teacher.
It's so important that you're not just
teaching them whatever
you're teaching them.
You're also teaching them like
life skills, social skills
like being a part of relationships.
It's so important.
And clearly you're such a
great teacher in that aspect.
So thank you for that.
- Yeah, I mean, they come
and hang out in my room,
almost every day whether
they're playing a sport or not.
And I think they're kind of craving that
like personal interaction, you know,
with the pandemic and everything going on.
So I think it's really special for me
to have that kind of
relationship with them
and it's important to them, so.
- Aw, thank you so much for being
such an amazing influence
on all these young people
and they were so happy for you, girl.
I'm happy for you as well.
I'm liking your post right now, all right?
- [Elise] Thank you.
- All right and that's not
all, our season one partner,
Pilot Pen, makers of friXion,
the go to erasable pen of
the Kelly Clarkson show,
want to celebrate those
creating fearlessly,
just like you ma'am,
so they're gonna give
you a thousand dollars,
just for being you.
(audience cheers)
(Kelly laughs)
- That was the best reaction.
Oh my God. Yes just for you.
You're gonna need it.
You're planning a wedding
- But thank you so much.